there are many gods and goddesses in
Egyptian mythology whose depiction has
changed over time and Bastet is a great
example of this she's often thought of
today as the cat goddess but she was
originally known as bass and it wasn't
until years later that the T at the end
of her name was even pronounced the
earliest depictions of best step did not
show her as a half cat half woman but
rather a woman with the head of a lion a
stet was the daughter of raw and she was
believed to have been associated with
the son and the concept of the you'll
see an eye over our over the years best
its association with the son dwindled
and her physical appearance changed to
that of a domestic cat she became the
goddess of the home fertility childbirth
and of course cats with cats being
considered protectors of the home in
Egyptian mythology images of Bastet
could be found scattered all throughout
the house believed to ward away evil
spirits and disease particularly those
that would affect women and children
Bastet was often associated with perfume
and the fine scent this belief was
further reinforced by the fact that she
was the mother to Nefer tomb the god of
perfume her name does suggest that she
was a kind to playful and graceful
goddess but underneath Bastet was a
fierce predator that still retained her
lioness persona she's often depicted as
holding a variety of objects each
symbolizing something new an anchor to
represent new life the papyrus wand that
was thought to represent the Lower Egypt
and a scepter that was thought to
signify strength it wasn't too uncommon
to see best at being accompanied by a
litter of fresh kittens in most
depictions it's no surprise that cats
were considered sacred to best debt and
the Egyptian people if harm was ever to
come to a cat it was considered a crime
against best debt and those responsible
would suffer an undesirable fate the
priests of best debts temple kept sacred
cats within the temple walls believed in
them to be incarnations of the goddess
herself
they were so highly valued by the
ancient Egyptians because they protected
the crops of farmers and they slowed the
spread of disease by killing vermin
another reason why Bastet might be seen
as a protective goddess being one of the
daughters of raw Bastet was commonly
referred to when discussing the eye of
raw she was also closely linked to the
other goddesses who formed the eye of
raw the most noticeable link was that of
Sekhmet as both goddesses took the form
of a lioness they were also both
considered to be the wife of pitar and
the mother to Netherton it was thought
that Sekhmet represented up he tipped
while Bastet represented lower egypt
eventually bested evolved into more of a
cat goddess and with this change came a
change in name from bass to best debt
Sekhmet on the other hand continued to
grow into her association with lions
there are those who believe that
bastard's cat-like appearance may be due
to her father raw because he took the
form of a cat when defeating the serpent
God Apophis the transformation of Bastet
may have also been influenced by the
ancient Greeks as small house cats were
considered skilled hunters the ancient
Greeks believed that bastet was very
similar to the goddess of the hunt
Artemis her name was slightly tweaked to
Basset and her form was changed to more
closely resemble Artemis making her a
moon goddess there's no doubt that over
the years best that was a goddess of
many associations but her primary role
was that of a protector I think much
like a pet cat best that brought the
ancient Egyptian families much comfort
knowing that the goddess was always with
them watching over them and protecting
them
I hope this video has managed to shed
some light as to why cats are so sacred
back in the ancient Egyptian times if
you guys enjoyed the video then let me
know your thoughts in the comments below
but as always I've been your host
mythology and fiction explained
[Music]